yeah Vitor Belfort is now going to 1fc
China and looks good again looking sexy
we're all filled out Eddie Alvarez I
yeah he got fucked oh yeah that dude he
fought Timothy Dukan Nass Dukan I think
this is his last name their guy's a
beast that one Fc show was legit yeah if
you watch it
I've watched just highlights I don't
have time to watch all the UFC fights
and then this time so it's hard to come
to watch the other cards as well but
once in a while watching Bellator I'll
watch one Fc yeah we'll do that I owe my
god his eyes locked up oh my god that's
terrible that's a terrible injury yeah
that looks like it split his eyelid did
oh my god Jesus Christ it split his
fucking eyelid dude oh my god people
people don't realize like that side of
it like I mean that's fucking well touch
your face I mean you had a little bit of
an MMA fight you know what it's like not
really yeah you did lose a fight another
comedian you beat him comedian up I'm
very impressive but hey it was he had a
Taekwondo held four times you take that
back you know people forget how to do
shit man if you all bullshit aside but
they also gave out a lot of talk mondo
black belts they're 100% horse it's part
of the business if you're not giving
your belts out how are you're not going
to get people to come back